on avait encore pas trop entendu tf1 sur
la sphère ppda patrick poivre d'arvor
patrick poivre d'arvor retour sur la
sphère ppda a conclu l'ancien
présentateur du jt de 20 heures est
accusé par 23 femmes d'agressions
sexuelles et de viol sur des faits
allant de 1985 à 2015 aujourd'hui la
première chaîne a décidé de lâcher son
ex présentateur et de faire un
documentaire sur les faits qui lui sont
reprochés une enquête qui sera intitulé
ppda et les femmes qui l'accusent
d'agressions sexuelles et de viol qui
sera diffusée dans sept à huit beaucoup
reprochaient tf1 de ne pas se mouiller
dans cette affaire c'est chose faite
alors tf1 prépare une enquête sur ppda
trouvez vous ça hypocrite de la part
alors à gilles verdez oui comme
d'habitude non mais c'est une vaste
hypocrisie pourquoi c'est un oui ils le
font c'est l'essentiel mais dans huit
ils ont les meilleurs fait diversier ils
sont très forts s'étaient équipés pour
faire ça depuis bien longtemps ils ne
faisaient pas pourquoi ils le font là et
pourquoi ces hypocrites pourquoi c'est
une tentative de sauver l'image de la
chaîne c'est parce que c'est impossible
pour eux de résister plus longtemps les
victimes présumées ont témoigné en
disant qu'il y avait un système où tf1
savez des gens savaient des gens ont
protégé donc ils sont obligés de le
faire ils le font dans l'urgence ils le
font par l'extérieur via sept à huit
chiffres ça d'une hypocrisie folle
est-ce qu'il va y avoir alors
visiblement ils sont très proches d'une
des victimes présumées date en fait
partie il y aura son témoignage a fait
partie de l'équipe oui voilà deux
éléphants conditions car à son
témoignage ensuite s'ils font ça c'est
parce qu'ils sont obligés de lâcher ppda
mais c'est uniquement de l'opportunisme
moi c'est ça qui me sidère ils ne l'ont
pas fait avant
parce que le succès d'audience
l'eau donc c'est du lard pour tunis mme
bernard tu es d'accord je suis tout à
fait d'accord c'est suite au succès de
nicolas hulot avec enquête au jeu
puisque
envoyé spécial et donc voilà c'est
simplement
ici avant bernard c'est assez incroyable
ce que vous dites est à dire qu ils sont
dix à fait non
la télé que c'est ce monde de la télé
tellement gentil moi j'essaie wafou que
je voulais absolument
ça fait des années ça fait des années
qu'il n'a plus aucun contact avec eux je
rappelle qu'ils sont partis en très très
moyen donc ils sont déjà à l'époque ils
s'en foutent total de pateras ils n'ont
jamais rappelés depuis donc voilà donc
ils le sortent opportunément après le
succès d' élise lucet c'était voilà on
envoie la sauce et on en voit là si vous
n'êtes quand il était en guerre
culturelle
ouverte pourquoi il aurait rappelé
isotherme et ça c'est un premier truc et
ensuite ils sont pas gays je me sens pas
hypocrites du tout c'est plus la même
direction c'est pas une production
interne justement
dsk était là oui ça va oui c'est
bérénice et
j'avais oublié mon chéri je serai pas
une petite fille prénommée j'avais
couple j'aime autant vous dire les noms
mais arrêtez d pad métis et danser dans
un an même pas l'anarchie a beaucoup ça
excuse moi mon chéri merci pour l'info
géraldine alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une
énorme tempête on a quand même
l'impression pardon que tf1 récupère un
tout petit peu les derniers soubresauts
et je trouve que c'est quand même
cynique ce qu'il faut c'est opportuniste
et je trouve que j ma maison c'est à
dire qu'on va parler des présumées
victimes elles sont 23 mais est-ce qu'on
va parler de la direction est-ce qu'on
va parler des cadres est ce que tf1 va
vraiment aller jusqu'au bout du procès
et à quoi aussi alors du coup un
reportage avec la sphère hulot parce que
l'eau était quand même une figure de
proue aussi de tf1 oui c'est d'une
bêtise parce qu'au contraire avec ce
documentaire tf1 prend beaucoup tabou
départ dont beaucoup de risques comment
ça va vous quels risques pour tf1 tf1
prend le risque verdure michel hné f1
prend le risque si ça se passe mal ppda
les lâches et si par hasard ppda
commence à dire ok moi c'est mort
commence à lâcher des noms lâcher les
noms des directions et la chine non sur
tf1 y aurait beaucoup plus à perdre fff
devrait faire rien dire pour le moment
et laisser la justice le fun donc ils
prennent beaucoup de risques et on
parlait de francs venture avec toujours
chez tf1 on a mis à part dont ils n'ont
pas être france 2 en disant ça sera même
faire un nom mais battus à la sathoan
n'arrêtait pas de dire voilà à 15h sur
france 2 quand est-ce qu'on fait
personne ne fait la tête ça ils vont
mettre les pieds dedans de surcroît un
peu à charge qu'il est bien foutu les
sens
j'aimerais non pas le barça c'est le
toque et au 20 août à l'arrêter chez
atos espère arrêter mathieu au service a
laissé entendre que la boîte d'emmanuel
chain cet avis aux services juridiques
instrumentalisé par tf1 grave aussi oui
oui c'est ma soeur ne travaille pas chez
tf1
708 faille tout fait tellement de talent
et esthétique chez tf1
et gratitude et c'est ce qu'elle a fait
7 à 8 qui bossent pour tf1 il en train
de dire que la boîte de 7 et 8
d'emmanuel chain est instrumentalisé
rare ça c'est pas vrai bah c'est ce
qu'il entend tenir ses séances
d'entraînement d'aujourd'hui
il susurré souple et ils ne peuvent pas
fait tout seul mais non
je veux dire c'est qu'une des
plaignantes contrepoids poivre d'arvor
est dans la boîte d'emmanuel chain je
peux comprendre que ça leur tiennent à
coeur mais oui parce qu'elle fait partie
du dispositif de 2,9 d'éléphant et
compagnie mais que dans l ordre dans un
attentat fait alors déjà vous dites
n'importe quoi mais là si je vous nomme
ici je vais vous le dire puisqu'on a
enquêté mais mes équipes et permet aux
enquêtés les journalistes ont enquêté
ils ont appelé la boîte et ils font et
compagnie la boîte de production qui
produit ils sont complètement démenti
cette info il n'y a personne qui
travaille là bas qui fait partie de la
sphère donc ça c'est une énorme connerie
voilà qui est une énorme légende donc
voilà donc déjà ça vole l'argument il
est haché c'est oui mais pardon mais
coupable ou pas coupable moi je trouve
que c'est une énorme trahison de la part
de tf1 alors c'est la trahison de presse
que c'est le travail certes des
journalistes ni les parties étaient
d'accord ça m'a expliqué ses travail du
journaliste de rapporter les
informations dont il ya une différence
entre faire une brève sans fioritures
comme ils l'ont fait dans le jt et faire
un reportage à charge hyper long et
accablant contre une star quand même
fait les belles heures de la chaîne et
je trouve qu'il ya d'autres chaînes pour
le faire c'est pas très sympa pour
regarder ce que disent les gens sur les
médias sociaux ne sont pas d'accord ils
vont ils sont plutôt d'accord et fils
avec berlin tube est un mec qui a accusé
de viol mais qui n'est pas ppda tu fais
un documentaire sur lui voilà donc c'est
pas ça s'appelle la télé
non mais là il a raison l'argument
bernard sur l'audience il est des
délibérations mais aussi beaucoup en est
en cause beaucoup la direction de tf1
marc dont je sais pas s'ils vont aller
juste que jusqu'à jusqu'à
vous aurez tf1 bouge pas il faut rien
dire ne rien mais c'est ouais mais oui
mais justement il ya des choses qu'ils
disent moi je trouve que c'est très bien
qu'ils le fassent au bout d'un moment
oui mais hier blanc même s'il vous plaît
ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui disent ils
le font parce qu'ils sont tellement fait
penser sur les réseaux sociaux et que
tout le monde a dit ils font et fo ayant
pour rien à un moment ils ont dit -
l'évêque va falloir qu'on fasse un truc
sur ppda parce que la spa possible pour
s'en prendre plein la gueule exane a
aussi haussé quand on sait exactement
comment ça se passe on est patient n'est
pas né de la dernière pluie et mathieu
tu sais très bien qu'à un moment un
moment quand tu quand tu vois que tout
le monde te dis il faut faire un truc
sur ppda vous croyez quoi communion
croyez qu'ils se fassent pasqua ouais
mais siegrist qui disait mais qu'on fait
rien sur ppda non non non à un moment
ils disent bon là on va se faire
retoquer il faut qu'on fasse un truc
donc sauf que ça laisserait entendre
pardon qu'ils ont pris le thé afin
qu'ils ont appelée ils ont pris leur
téléphone ils ont rempli la boîte essai
de 7 à 8 pour dire voilà vous allez
faire un truc sur ppda mais je vais vous
dire un petit peu dans lequel on ne le
fait pas du tout ça j'ai du mal à venir
je pense que la boîte éléphants
compagnie a déjà proposé des choses sur
ppda qui ont été refusées et la refuser
refusé refusé et un moment ils ont dit
henri gagnon écouté et je pense que là
on va dire oui laissez les faire voilà
et en plus ils savent qu'ils savent
faire donc il dit on va le faire en plus
vous et voilà je pense que c'est c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé c'est tout
bête c'est passé très fins et c'est pas
une commande c'est un moment ils sont ni
aller on le fait sur l'image de l'équipe
en place et pas du tout la même qu'il ya
dix ans bah oui là ne peut pas parler
sur tf1 qu'il a un contrat je rappelle
qu'il a signé un gros contrat avec une
pompe pour ne pas rien dire sont tf1
donc ya pas grand risque pour tf1 et
c'est effectivement moi le sait mieux
vaut tard que jamais effectivement il
sait pour leur image à eux après avoir
zappé ou en avion sera évidemment marché
évidemment bien sûr j'ai pas tout
compris
ma mère chez moi compris je l'envoie
mais c'est ce que je sais moi je trouve
je pense qu'il ya d'autres chaînes pour
le faire il ya d'autres chaînes qui se
sont intéressés à lui je trouve ça pas
classe qu'une chaîne est la mienne mais
son but est de faire le tour s'il
l'avait pas fait ils m'ont traitée dans
leur gîte emilia des manières
d'éditorialiser les infos selon si la
personne est dans la maison ou pas je
pense qu'avec des temps réalisés c'est
une formation mais non j'ai un père une
information c'est pas vrai je sais très
bien que les rédac chef et choisissait
ce qu'on en fait une brève dans le jt ou
est-ce que
ça n'a aucun sens oui oui ça va aussi
sur la chaîne il se passe un truc avec
bart debie on le fera voilà on le fera
je le dis oui gbahi mais on n'arrête pas
de dire ici par exemple 2 élise lucet si
elle faisait un truc ce serait
formidable c'est bien un truc sur france
télé balance de cela tu dis ne faites
pas ils font ces normes ne fâchent pas
garde non pas que le passé quel
commentaire devant chez elle tous les
produits audio guérilla notait les
choses mais vous enfin si pierre ménès y
avait des trucs qui s'est invité dans le
parti du lac on a parlé des missions ici
à la réunion des rallyes dans la famille
attend mais sinon les gens ils
comprennent the cover on a on a osé va
bien chaud qu'on a osé concentrant
pendant des
mois l'a fait et on est et on était le
menton pierre voilà un voilà c'est bon
ou pas bon alors composants penser qu'on
va voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
tiens oui à 71% non à 28% voyez les gens
tout ça hypocrite de leur part voilà
j'aime bien encore une fois croit
deschamps sont d'accord avec nous merci
et vous vous croyez toujours les gens
sont beaucoup plus intelligents et
téléspectateurs parce que vous croyez
alors pas du tout dans un canapé est pas
de bêtises il ya des gens qui étaient à
la direction à l'époque qu'elles sont
encore donc ne dit pas de page il
concentre exemple si je vous dis on a
énormément dit wang et is je compte je
pense que je connais mieux la direction
que vous et ne prenez pas les
téléspectateurs pour des imbéciles
sachez qu'ils savaient ils sont beaucoup
plus d'infos que nous certainement